[موسيقى]
النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام قال الحلال ما
حل الله في كتابه
والحرام محرم الله في كتابه الو ما سكت
عنه فوعفو فاقبلوا من الله عافيه فعندنا
دائره واسعه في الاسلام جدا هي دائره
العفو يا دائره المسكوت عنه وهي الدائره
الاكبر
ياتي المجتهدون المبدعون المفكرون الا
المفترض ان طلاب الدكتوراه والماجستير
واساتذه الجامعه يكونوا على هذا القدر من
الفكر يعملوا ايه قال يملاوا هذه المنطقه
الفارغه بما يحقق مصادر
[موسيقى]
وده اللي نرجع لحتى تفضلت به للشيخ محمد
عبده الشيخ محمد عبده قامت عليه ضجه لانه
الشيخ محمد عبده فاهم ان العالم لابد ان
يقوم بواجب الوقت واجب الوقت ايه كما قلت
انك انت تفهم المجتمع وكيف تخاطب الناس
بالاسلام الناس عقول متغيره والفقهان من
قديم قالوا تتغير الاحكام بتغير الزمان
والمكان والاشخاص والاحوال
[موسيقى]